can you spit some [ __ ] right now
yo straight up so it's this poem that i
got
called love is not enough
i don't know much about love
but i know that in some cases love is
not enough love will have you chasing
waterfalls and deserts
love will have you flipping through the
pages of an empty book looking for its
definition
love doesn't always equal loyalty i
understand why kendrick said keep it a
hunter i rather you trust me than to
love me because what is love trust ain't
there who cares about being locked in a
room with him if it's always a fuss in
there love is an ice pick it will poke
you love is a pistol it will smoke you
love ain't always sweet like smuckers
but it'll jam you up that [ __ ] will
toast you love will leave you broken
screaming alexa play death around the
corner by tupac shakur alexa play
madonna love don't live here anymore
alexa play dmx slipping cause i'm
falling and i can't get up alexa play a
baltimore love thing by 50 cent i'd
rather use pinky nail to feed now
through fitting on it to be here stuck
on stupid alexa please play cupid by
saying cut love was born a bullet i'm
hitting shock trauma i'm shook alexa it
seemed like you the only god i know who
answered me on demand alexa why i love
ain't got no do right i've been fighting
all my life but what happens when your
knuckles used to rearrange jaw lines now
your bones crack when you whisper alexa
i just want my cinderella and glass
slipper why is love the game of the
century i ain't no bobby fisher but you
see my chest panel lies a lonely king
and a fraudulent bishop passing for a
queen love is righteous island of
bingham track my songs i sing a
hummingbird in the trenches but i can't
locate my wings around here flying be
non-existent listen love will have you
love will hold you hostage love is three
six mafia they're about to find your
body beverage on from the death of a
mosh pit your angel on your right
shoulder saying try something different
as you begin to smoke your life away but
love is not a five-star stay love is not
in all expenses paid vacay love is not
attention last night in your face look
around they gone today love had my
granny putting a lien on her house to
bail my mother out of jail love ain't
fresh like granny's cookies made from
scratch you see at times love be still
you see love got you running the streets
crushed living on the cracks of your
mouth blood got you scratching your neck
you see
love is the leading cause of death but
it's hard to find a solution when you
admire the problem it's hard to seek
justice when your brother is the [ __ ]
who shot him love deposit souls demand
people for profit real love only exists
in music movies books and lockets love
made me want to sell my soul use the
proceeds the painter i'm with insane
that i'm saying love is a bad day rent
you ain't [ __ ] but limp balls and your
jeans love is a deferred dream love
stinks like rotten meat love sags like a
heavy low love explode love don't be
sticking to the [ __ ] people
let me see
love will have you
love will hold you
i will smile on your face with a
mouthful of pearly whites
i always keep one eye open because love
be switching up
she looked me in my eyes and said
love is all we got
i said don't hold your breath baby
because love
is not enough
[Music]
you